from major disasters and freak accidents
to a starry night sky
you'd be shocked to know how much of
grey's anatomy is actually created by
cgi
stargate studios has definitely had
their work cut out for them
but we had no idea that they brought so
many scenes from grey's anatomy to life
which major character was actually cgi'd
into the pilot episode
why was lexi gray's recent appearance
done with cgi
what surprising locations are actually
set in front of green screens
welcome to the game we were equally
shocked and delighted to see lexi gray
with meredith again
unfortunately they weren't actually
together at all
while the editing did an amazing job at
making it seem as though that were the
case
lexi's return was all cgi lee was based
in vancouver canada filming another
series at the time greys needed her
and due to the strict travel regulations
she wasn't able to reunite in person
ellen pompeo and eric dane filmed
together in person and
spent a fair amount of time looking and
talking towards nothing
imagining lee to be there with them
since they've managed to include a
former cast member with cgi this season
we're hoping we'll get to see way more
guest appearances from our favorite
characters
that's a pretty good favorite thing
surprisingly this
isn't actually the first time that an
actor was cgied in
in fact this technology has come in
handy since day one
literally the first day we see all the
hospital interns in the pilot episode we
don't see khareb too much
and that's because he was never actually
in the episode to begin with
the pilot was shot a while before it got
picked up and once it was
shonda rhimes felt there needed to be
another character thrown into the mix
they wanted to include a kind of jerk
character
hugh justin chambers there is actually
one scene in the pilot though that was
added after the initial filming where we
see karev and meredith having a
one-on-one
maybe we'll see him again via cgi this
season do exactly as she
says then tell your resident that i want
you off this case
remember this rooftop scene with yang
and derek wine
a beautiful evening in seattle it all
looks lovely but
not only was it actually probably not
that time of day
the scene wasn't even filmed outdoors
the two actors were inside and just
surrounded by a green screen
only for the seattle skyline to be
incorporated after the fact
this is probably the cgi use that
surprised us the most
we've come to know grace sloane so well
that we could probably direct someone to
an or if we needed to
however the hospital we see is not what
exists in reality
this famous view from the walkway
overlooking the lobby cgi
even random hallways and offices have
green screens in the windows that have
editing done to make it appear as if the
rooms are in specific locations in the
hospital
check out this classroom scene with
meredith interns and a whole lot of
bodies
we never could have guessed this would
be courtesy of cgi
we've always wondered how the team so
convincingly brought arizona's both
lack of leg and prosthetic leg to the
screen first let's check out what it
looks like when she's just missing part
of her leg
we can see it simply cgi'd out of the
shot so how about the inclusion of the
prosthetic
well that part actually wasn't part of
the effects at all
jessica capshaw was actually wearing a
prosthetic leg that attached to her leg
and the part of her leg that was
supposed to appear as missing was just
bent behind the prosthetic itself
for any glimpses of her actual leg that
needed to be taken care of
cgi did the trick for a hospital drama
the show
actually spends quite a bit of time
outside the hospital
the space literally just outside the
hospital it's all cgi
the parking lot the walls of grace lone
memorial
we were really surprised that such an
iconic location would just be the result
of a green screen
oh my bypass patience and defense you
know go go go go safely
actually the outdoors in general are all
pretty much just computer generated
april at the bottom of this hill and a
river well the actress was
much safer and much drier in reality it
turns out
most of the scenes that take place in
other locations and have windows
indicating where the characters are or
what time of day it might be
well the views aren't quite what we see
in the show
we loved seeing derek and meredith's
dream house being built but
as we can see here the lot is just
another cgi creation
the peaks we get at the signature
seattle skyline are also just vfx
how would he know that while the
majority of the complicated cgi looks
amazing
these helicopters are always a bit of a
fail
from all the rooftop helicopter scenes
either receiving or sending patients off
to helicopters coming into the rescue in
one of the many moments of disaster in
the series
it always looks a bit fake oh and for
all the scenes that take place
within the helicopters the actors are
actually just sitting safely in a studio
with green screen or blue screen
surrounding them
much less daunting but the performances
are always spot-on
oh god okay all right okay
every time derek has appeared in the
series since he passed we've been here
for it
all these appearances except for his
most recent times spent on the beach
with meredith
have been brought to us by cgi they
didn't use new footage
we usually got the flashes of mcdreamy's
charming smile and
knowing looks while they've always been
touching the technology
isn't quite as flawless as we'd hope so
sometimes
it does look a bit odd episode 6 of the
15th season is probably the best example
of this
we loved the walk through memory lane
with past favorites but
derek and mark standing there it doesn't
quite hit the mark visually
can i come over we see a lot of intense
and wild stuff on grey's anatomy
loads of characters who are missing
limbs dislocated shoulders
conjoined twins as we can see the actors
look
very different without all the editing
that makes these a reality
the way these physical abnormalities
look as shocking as they are
is still pretty convincing while we
expect some of the more technically
medical scenes and disaster shots to
have some cgi done
we were really surprised to see what
maggie's running trail actually looks
like
not nearly as nice but who knew the
simple nature shot would have effects
added at all
i didn't know you were a runner oh yeah
while we all missed seeing christina
yang on a regular basis
we did love seeing her in her new boss
role in zurich
but in reality she wasn't too far at all
yang shot these scenes in the states
with a green screen behind her
in editing it was the cgi team who
brought the views of christina living
her best
zurich life to the screen this giant
hole in the middle of the city
we're definitely glad this shot was cgi
as we've seen many spots in the hospital
are a fabrication of cgi anyway
so you can bet that these flames in the
stairway were courtesy of special
effects as well
it makes sense that these disaster
scenes like this boat explosion at the
docks
are brought to life with technology
since a it's extremely dangerous
and b it would probably put the show's
budget through the roof
go help people we've covered a few
specific group scenes already but
the fact is all the roof scenes are cgi
no matter if it's christina and meredith
waiting for a patient to arrive
or the boys working on their golf swings
when in the or we know that the actors
aren't actually performing any surgery
but it's neat to see how the bodies are
marked on set in order to add these
impressively real looking inner organs
with cgi after the fact
can anybody name the common causes of
post-op fever
while we definitely expected there to be
some cgi in the series
we were honestly shocked to discover how
many mundane and seemingly simple or
typical scenes needed cgi done
regardless of how awkward it can look at
times we will always love and welcome a
derek come back
who doesn't want to look at that
mcdreamy face which moment of cgi
surprised you the most
we're gonna go with the casual hospital
[Music]
areas
[Music]
you